everybody my name is Jake Archie from
Bandai Namco we're playing Dark Souls 3
the game is on April 12th we're here a
little earlier some guests from Silicon
Valley and we're gonna get right into it
I am TJ Miller from yogi berra 3d and I
am the mucinex man mr. mucus it's not
celebrity and I'm also on Silicon Valley
which i think is the reason that I'm
here a huge gaming fan a long time
gaming fan first time gamer
hi I'm Kumail Nanjiani from Silicon
Valley and we are gonna play Dark Souls
I don't take games seriously my
self-respect and self-esteem does not
depend on video games I don't get
obsessed and watch me not get obsessed I
think you pronounce today of our company
you're wrong it's it's Silicon Valley
thank god
badly yeah that's right
[Music]
Dark Souls 3 words aren't happening so
words are rounded to :
we can watch the white watch the intro I
love laughing or the transitory lands of
the Lord cinder converge I always
wondered when those transitory land
company coming so much at us already
I love it oh these this is why posture
everyday not be a minute like daily
meditation but tough day carrying giant
turtles on your back so this is kind of
a dark game it's very dark it's the
heart of it is really he forgot to bring
his face little-known fact he can only
fit into a Cadillac STS or whatever
reason that's the only car that he can
really get his axe in there
yeah the accent was a lot of trunk room
or the app but you're into the fantasy
stuff oh yeah see I haven't played what
was the one that you said you played a
little bit of blood-borne color he just
wants to give this guy plastic surgery
we're gonna finish making her character
then we're gonna go find the five Lords
and bring them back to their Thrones you
gotta figure out why they left those
Thrones which all main accounts to the
truth to the Lord sleeve of Thrones yep
as I say to Kate every morning but you
once you find the truth then you find
the Lord's put the Lord's back on the
Thrones the fire keeps going yep I can't
wait that's the idea easy-peasy any
ethnicity well before that let's all go
out one of us is Japanese I'm just
cutting the marsh around him to the fish
[Music]
because you hate them up in there eating
me on Friday you just setting the
precedent and by your hubris it'd be
like seemed perfect
quickly elixir elixir Alexa I just give
me a second that was really scary how
you got out of it see you're a good
night and all female
the fog nice
it is so unfair look at the size of that
guy in the thing that's the first boss
now I turn around he's a little bit of a
challenge pretty good
what's the sorting is usually try to
roll out of the way alright mister you
gotta come a lot of Oi
hey this houseboat yes it is oh yeah
that's good dear nice dude nice nice oh
okay the rules
oh dude that's amazing this better than
last time what do I do
I know everybody wants us to move on but
I'm gonna try one more time
everyone's talking about how we can't
beat this guy and then they'll move on
to the next level
remember they want to show this game we
gotta beat this guy look how good he
just doing to do it amazing this is
going great
this is a box - enough
idea what
No
yeah
he can't sleep tonight I was afraid I
wouldn't feel anything but I feel that
you feel that I'm sorry yeah I feel good
oh my god very good
we get it you're forming God these
people take forever
oh sorry people I hope dragon liquid
battle machine Lord that makes your
timing that you can't jump certain
disciplines he did
the next plan alright so we've been
playing Dark Souls 3 for a little bit
and we start skipping way ahead into the
game we're we're bloated up my save and
we're gonna fight a boss that actually
haven't beat
your chip is that a color bowl again
it's called the Kure or are you gonna
beat up I mean yeah well now he'd beat
the dragon said that before but now
watch you gotta fight the man yeah the
man behind the dragon damages alright
well I'd like to say you do it again
yeah I know I really still feel bad how
you treated me but I will say this I am
addicted to Dark Souls well today it was
tough guys but we beat some bosses so
thank you so much
we did more digging kumail beats and
bosses J all of us killed the CI no
secret boss and a terrific yeah you know
the death of the nameless King and in
between tanks I texted my wife and I
guess we're gonna have a threesome with
an English prostitute this afternoon but
you guys have fun I'm glad
[Music]